chaque semaine le rendez vous
immanquable des molènes b quoi le grand
marché de la place communale
bachir est éducateur dans ce quartier
populaire où il a grandi c'est ça oui
c'est la vie pas les autres villes
vivent normalement quoi en bonne
intelligence - totalement quoi et ça
c'est la majorité des habitants de la
commune et pourtant en novembre dernier
la réputation de molenbeek s'est
brutalement terre ni aux yeux du monde
entier
pour beaucoup la commune est devenue
l'épicentre du terrorisme islamiste
j'ai l'impression que le ciel nous tombe
sur la tête comme dirait astérix et
c'est vrai qu'on s'attendait pas
déferlement pareil quoi c'est clair on
essaie de se remettre
ce n'est pas encore tout à fait ça mais
oui je suis triste pour ce boulot pour
l'image des quartiers de ce qu'il est
réellement molenbeek saint jean et ses
cent mille habitants sont à dix minutes
du centre ville de bruxelles en tramway
entre les deux un canal cette frontière
naturelle symbolise aujourd'hui la mise
à l'écart de la seconde commune la plus
pauvre de belgique
ici le chômage frappe une jeunesse
désoeuvrée chez les 18 25 ans la moitié
sont sans emploi un cocktail explosif
qui peut favoriser la radicalisation
elle est très difficile à cerner si elle
est propre moment et parents de jeunes
qui ont fait ses conneries pour
participer n'ont pas senti que ça
pouvait arriver
comment nous sommes des personnes lambda
pour le savoir et s'ils ont des
mauvaises intentions dans ce sens et
nous le dirons pas c'est pourquoi la
municipalité a créé une cellule de
déradicalisation 2014
actuellement une trentaine de familles
sont suivies par des psychologues et des
sociologues
le constat est souvent le même il ya
toujours quelque chose qui s'est jouée
au sein de la famille il peut y avoir un
conflit
il peut y avoir une séparation un d'une
relation bruce qui s'est mal terminée
pour lequel le jeune un certain âge mais
c'est de chercher des réponses non pas
au sein de la famille mais à l'extérieur
il peut trouver au niveau de ses copains
bas au niveau aussi des personnes plus
malveillant qui vont essayer de
l'endoctriner
nous retrouvons bachir dans les locaux
de son association le foyer
au début c'est bien comprise et des ados
il en a accompagné des centaines un
travail de terrain précieux sa pédagogie
la culture du langage et l'éducation
pour lui c'est l'antidote absolue au
radicalisme
si on veut parler de radicalisme preuve
c'est qu'il ya une ignorance de ces
jeunes là parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
culture est en tout cas qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à les ouvrir un livre
pour s'informer de ce qui est réel et ce
qui ne l'est pas au lieu de mettre du
fric dans le répressif c'est à dire
police armée mettons du fric dans le
savoir dans une autre pièce
les plus grands eux dénoncent cette
injustice qu'ils subissent savard dans
une commune où les dotations de l'état
sont en baisse constante
on donne pas c'est la chance aux jeunes
c'est pour ça que ces jeunes là sont un
peu perdus un peu court mais dans la
société
et quand il trouve une occasion de fuir
abeilles vont fuir parce qu'on leur
promette une belle vie ailleurs
maintenant une personne qui a un travail
qui est ni puis social qui est -ce qui a
tout ici je pense pas qu'il va aller qui
va se radicaliser
du côté des mosquées on refuse les
amalgames dans une ville trop hâtivement
présenté comme un ghetto islamiste et je
n'essaie de moulins mecs sont des jeunes
qui ne fréquentent pas les mosquées
ce sont des jeunes qui ont été recrutés
qui ont été engagés sur les réseaux
sociaux et aussi par des réseaux mafieux
qui utilisent l'islam à d'autres femmes
qui instrumentalisent l'islam
que se passe-t-il réellement à molenbeek
les programme de déradicalisation sont
ils efficaces
la belgique at elle pris conscience trop
tard du phénomène dans le débat
politique
la question est posée il n'y a pas eu
assez tôt une approche répressive de ce
phénomène il ya eu au nom du
multiculturalisme une très grande
tolérance devant ces mouvements radicaux
devant des mouvements salafistes demandé
mouvement extrêmement extrémistes qui
sont devenus au bout d'un temps pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux d'entre eux
violent il faut qu'il y ait une double
critique à la fois au sein des
communautés musulmanes mais il faut
qu'ils ont aussi une critique de la
société
qu'avons nous rater en matière
d'intégration sociale qu'avons nous
rater en matière de lutte contre les
discriminations pour que ces enfants qui
sont nos enfants en ville à se retourner
contre le pays qui les a vu grandir
depuis 2012 plus de 400 belges auraient
quitté leur pays pour combattre en syrie
ou en irak
c'est deux fois plus que la france par
million d'habitants